après les chars occidentaux des
chasseurs bombardiers bientôt envoyés en
Ukraine une petite révolution car ses
avions appartiennent à la Pologne et
jusqu'à présent aucun pays de l'Otan
avait donné son feu vert pour la
livraison de telles appareils à
l'Ukraine Varsovie vient de franchir le
pas
dans un premier temps dans les prochains
jours nous allons transférer quatre
appareils 1029 pleinement opérationnels
à l'Ukraine les autres avions qui sont
actuellement en cours de maintenance et
préparer seront successivement envoyés
ces avions polonais datent des années 90
et sont de fabrication soviétiques les
soldatsukrainiens savent donc déjà les
utiliser et les réparer un atout mais
pas un avantage dans la guerre contre la
Russie car ces appareils sont anciens
l'Ukraine l'a d'ailleurs rappelé elle
aimerait avoir accès aux fameux
chasseurs F16 américain plus récents et
plus performant les mig ne résoudront
pas les problèmes nous avons besoin de
F- 16 mais les mig contribueront à
renforcer nos capacités une ligne rouge
pour les États-Unis qui ont réitéré leur
refus de fournir de telles armes à Kiev
en Europe la Slovaquie réfléchit à
imiter la Pologne et envoyer les 12
chasseurs soviétiques